The comment section on this one is gonna be
hell.
Do your worst, you filthy animals.
Now, before we begin today’s video, let’s
clear some things up.
We know exactly what you’re thinking.
“An Among Us SCP?
This sounds ridiculous!
Why would the Foundation ever have to deal
with an anomaly relating to Among Us, of all
things?
Is this some sick joke dreamt up by our YouTube
commenters?”
And we get it.
It’s definitely one of the more ridiculous
anomalies the Foundation has had to contain,
at least at face value.
But there are a few things you should take
into consideration before things get too Amogus-pilled
around here.
First, this is hardly the strangest anomaly
we’ve covered on SCP Explained!
SCP-5981, also known as Nuke City, revolved
around a mysterious broadcast of a Family
Guy episode!
SCP-4335, a Welt in the Crucible, had to deal
with an entity occupying space inside the
video game Minecraft.
But there are countless other examples of
anomalies creeping into popular culture, mutating
it, and twisting it for their own purposes.
What may seem silly on paper, such as the
Foundation having to do research on a popular
video game like Among Us, is all part of what
the organization does.
If the brave researchers at the SCP Foundation
chuckled and brushed off a potential threat
just because it had to do with something like
Among Us, the entire population might be susceptible
to a supernatural event of unprecedented proportions.
The Foundation’s entire Veil of secrecy
could crumble, all because someone shrugged
off the possibility of allocating resources
to deal with a threat millions of civilians
could discover.
These games, movies, and shows are immensely
popular, and an anomaly affecting a global
phenomenon like Among Us could spell doom
for not only the Foundation, but the entire
world as well, if left unchecked.
So, if you don’t want to risk termination,
please try to keep a straight face as we divulge
into the weird and wacky story of SCP-5167,
an anomaly codenamed in the Foundation’s
database as “When the Impostor is Sus”.
I hate my job sometimes.
To begin, we need to go back.
Way, way back.
Centuries before Among Us was even conceived
as a concept, before video games had been
invented, and even before electricity itself
was discovered.
Back to an era where the gods of Olympus ruled
supreme, and stone, marble statues lined buildings
that would serve as timeless feats of architecture,
and where a new school of thought was developing.
One that focused on logic and reason instead
of superstition and hearsay.
That’s right, we’re talking about ancient
Greece.
A society that, for all of its achievements
and progression in the fields of education,
cultures, and logic, was still largely governed
by religion and mythology.
But of course, as you may come to expect when
dealing with the SCP Foundation, there’s
always a little truth in that which we cannot
understand.
While those who are unaware of the paranormal
might deride the Greeks for being overly focused
on a pantheon of gods they logically should
have had no reason to believe, those who know
that anything can happen in the world of the
anomalous may approach this topic, and the
subject of religion in general, in a different
light.
The Greek gods were very real.
While the myths may not be entirely true,
and they may not have been literal gods, there
were a group of anomalous entities who influenced
Greek society, performing miraculous feats
that left those who observed them in complete
wonder and putting together cults of worship
surrounding them.
While most of this was done in secret, word
of these beings traveled incredibly fast in
the ancient world, and they were heralded
as gods.
Beings of divine might that could do anything
in the universe, who existed above the mortal
plane, and demanded worship from their followers.
A glance at Greek mythology paints a picture
of a group of gods who acted, more or less,
like humans.
They fought, they killed, they argued, and
they felt human emotions.
It’s likely that this characterization in
the stories emerged from how these entities
conducted themselves in actuality.
There were dozens upon dozens of entities
the Greeks worshiped as divinity, and while
the stories portrayed the gods as jealous,
vengeful beings, who constantly fought with
each other, it doesn’t compare to the reality
of the situation, which was much more cut-throat.
You see, there were the twelve gods of Olympus,
and you probably know most of them.
They’re remembered today for a reason.
Zeus, Athena, Poseidon, Ares, the list goes
on.
We still remember these beings because of
the iconic stories they took part in, and
how significant they were in ancient times.
Well, for every Zeus, God of Lightning, there
were five more gods who absolutely no one
but the most hardcore historical fanatic remember.
Gods of niche subjects, who had small followings,
who never had those character-defining myths
to flesh them out and preserve them for all
of history to remember.
Who would, when Greece fell, fade into obscurity.
For every Zeus, there was a Phthonus.
Who was Phthonus, you ask?
Well, if the guy heard you asking that question,
he’d probably smite you down before the
question even left your lips…
If he wasn’t engaged in a hardcore game
of Among Us, that is.
Don’t worry, we’ll get there.
All will be explained.
It’s in the name of the channel, after all.
Phthonus was a god of jealousy and envy, mainly
in a romantic context.
Do you have a crush on someone who's already
taken?
Phthonus knows all about that.
Do you wish you weren’t trapped in a dead-end
relationship with someone who doesn’t love
you?
Phthonus understands your plight.
But Phthonus wasn’t just a reverse, bizarro
Cupid.
He was a literal personification of the emotions
of jealousy and envy themselves.
No matter the context, if it was petty and
greedy, Phthonus knew it all too well.
You would think this would make Phthonus a
prime candidate for some mythological drama,
right?
After all, the Greek gods loved their in-fighting,
and who better to stir up some “Hera said,
Zeus said” arguments than a literal god
of envy?
Well, it didn’t quite work out that way
for Phthonus.
His appearances in myths were infrequent,
and today, he is nearly all but forgotten.
Reduced to a mere three sentences on a Wikipedia
page, while other figures from his era have
taken on an entire new life in the modern
day, as cultural icons like Perseus or Hercules.
But not poor Phthonus, whose penchant for
jealousy and envy backfired on him, and catapulted
him into obscurity.
Why did this happen?
It’s kind of obvious, when you think about
it.
While other gods granted their worshippers
a good harvest, or copious amounts of wine
and partying, all that Phthonus had to offer
was, well, the ugly side of humanity.
His worshippers were far and few between.
After all, no one wanted their entire life
to revolve around the jealousy of others,
and Phthonus, being a personification of envy,
had an understandably difficult time getting
people to devote themselves to him.
Phthonus was greedy and envied the other gods.
So while he would accept nothing but absolute
worship from his followers, he couldn’t
offer much else, especially not when compared
to the bountiful boons a great god like Zeus
or Hera could offer.
And so, Phthonus festered.
An ugly god, who wallowed in self-hatred and
irrelevancy, constantly living in the shadow
of the pantheon that gave him purpose.
And his purpose was to remain jealous.
To remain envious of those who had what he
did not.
A god unfit to be worshiped, whose purpose
was to embody the feelings of wanting what
isn’t yours.
Phthonus is both tragic, and poetic, and when
the Greeks faded away, so too did Phthonus.
The Roman Empire, who largely adapted Greece’s
pantheon of gods for their own stories, left
no record of bringing Phthonus into the mix.
For centuries, he was a god without a home,
attempting to find a place in a changing world.
Phthonus was angry, jealous, envious, and
tired.
The forces of the universe would call him
forth in every new era, thrusting him back
into the world and forcing him to search for
the sustenance beings that were referred to
as gods fed off of - devotion.
But every time Phthonus would find himself
walking the earth once again, he would instead
discover that there was no place for him.
Mankind was moving on.
There was less and less room for gods with
every passing year.
All the popular ones had established themselves
as everlasting religious figures at this point,
and they would never fade away.
Some took pleasure in living among humans,
rising to power as people of influence and
fame.
Others, who could not find a place in the
world, would fade away, never to be revived
or worshiped ever again.
Forgotten, dead gods, who the world long outgrew.
But Phthonus’ jealous spirit would never
allow him to consign himself to that fate.
He hated who he was and what he stood for,
but that nature brought him back so many times
before.
It was his jealousy of the other gods, who
were somehow managing to linger beyond their
Greek heyday, that caused him to persevere.
He needed a purpose.
One last chance to be remembered.
He had struggled for centuries, and this was
his last-ditch effort to be remembered.
Wherever he would wake up, in the modern era,
Phthonus would have to make the most of it.
And this is where Among Us comes in.
In late 2020, The SCP Foundation was just
as captivated as anyone else by the Among
Us phenomenon.
A game that was sweeping the globe, where
players took on the roles of crewmates on
a spaceship, one of which was an impostor,
whose job was to secretly murder the other
players.
While they were busy doing tasks that ranged
from scanning themselves in the medbay, or
scanning keycards in the admin room, the impostor
would be lurking behind every corner, sometimes
in the ship’s air-vents, waiting for the
proper moment to strike.
If a dead body was found, a player could report
it, and the players would then discuss which
one of them they suspected to be the impostor.
The game’s addictive psychological elements
and accessible rules made it a smash hit,
but for the Foundation, they were infatuated
with it for entirely different reasons.
You see, when a piece of media attains the
level of fame that Among Us did, the Foundation
has to make sure to keep their eyes on it.
Popular media is a prime target for anomalies.
The population’s collective attention on
it just seems to invite the forces of the
supernatural world to warp and distort what
we know to be familiar.
And this is exactly what was happening to
Among Us.
For months, the Foundation was documenting
cases of an entity who appeared in games of
Among Us and caused havoc in the real world.
These cases, and their after-effects, were
so severe that the Foundation deemed the anomaly
significant enough to get its own file in
the database, designating it under the name
SCP-5167.
SCP-5167 would join games of Among Us like
any other player.
They would blend in, much like the impostor
in the game, and play just as anyone else
would.
It was what happened after a player participated
in a session with SCP-5167 that had the Foundation
investigating every aspect of the game.
Those who played with SCP-5167 would find
themselves stricken by a severe case of paranoia
and Capgras delusion, a psychological condition
in which a victim would come to believe those
around them had been replaced with identical
impostors.
The severity of this disorder varied between
individuals, but some believed the delusions
to such an extent that they lashed out at
those they believed to be impostors, sometimes
resulting in a homicide.
Naturally, the Foundation put two and two
together, which led back to Among Us.
After several months of police cases relating
to completely average individuals suddenly
striking out at their loved ones, sometimes
killing them, and showing signs of Capgras
delusion, the organization knew that something
was happening on an anomalous scale.
At first, it was difficult to make the connection
to Among Us, but the Foundation eventually
learned, from interviews with victims and
an examination of their habits over the past
few weeks, that they had all played the game.
And through analysis of the Among Us community’s
various trends and habits, the Foundation
discovered SCP-5167, an entity that was slowly
gaining notoriety within the game’s community
as an almost mythological figure.
SCP-5167’s tendency to spout long, wordy
rants at other players during the game’s
emergency meeting sessions positioned them
as an inside joke for those who encountered
them.
Needing to establish a link between these
anomalously induced bouts of paranoia, the
Foundation set up a group of web-crawler AIs
to track Among Us game sessions until SCP-5167
would appear.
It was a long shot, but it was one of many
different theories on why these victims were
undergoing this level of psychosis, and if
it proved to be true, then the Foundation
would have a solid idea of what to do next.
After weeks of nothing, SCP-5167 was spotted
in a game, and the Foundation acted quickly
to track down the other players who played
alongside the entity.
Naturally, they exhibited signs of paranoia
and delusion, some of them only for weeks,
and others for months.
That was enough evidence for the Foundation,
who would later document several other occurrences
of games with SCP-5167 resulting in these
psychiatric conditions in other players.
The Foundation did what they do best, and
established a series of Special Containment
Procedures that would wipe SCP-5167 from the
internet as best as they could.
Web crawlers were trained to take down any
mentions of the entity, and if a potential
sighting was discovered, the Foundation would
investigate any and all players involved in
the incident.
Anyone affected by SCP-5167 would be held
under the guise of receiving medical treatment
for mental health issues, and they would be
amnesticized completely.
You might be thinking that the aftereffects
of SCP-5167 are relatively tame compared to
what the Foundation usually deals with, but
look at it this way.
Among Us is a game played by millions of people.
If SCP-5167 affected only a fraction of that
population, it would spell total chaos for
the Foundation.
Not only that, but the amount of bloodshed
the entity could cause would be nothing to
scoff at, as a large amount of cases dealt
with victims outright murdering anyone they
suspected to be an impostor.
Attempts to track down the SCP-5167 entity
were met with failure.
All points of internet access that the Foundation
was able to get their hands on only led to
a series of abandoned home addresses in rural
Greece.
But over time, things started to change.
The Foundation began to place less of a concern
on SCP-5167.
It was almost as if the entity was being forgotten.
Why?
This letter, addressed to the SCP-5167 research
team from the Site’s director, might clear
some things up.
As requested by Head Researcher Abrams, I've
had the Site-22 analysts look into the progress
of SCP-5167's anomalous effects over the period
we've observed it — and the results are
much as I expected.
When we first discovered SCP-5167 — for
the sake of argument, let's say this is when
SCP-5167 first came into existence — the
impact it had on its victims was severe.
I don't think I have to remind you of what
Billy Heth did to his family's faces.
But since then — almost immediately, really,
since that first couple of manifestations
— the potency of its effects has started
to decline.
Full detachment from reality became delusion,
and delusion has now become paranoia - and
the intensity of that paranoia is lessening
in each new case.
This is all conjecture, of course, and shouldn't
be taken as gospel — but based on what we've
observed of this anomaly thus far, our estimation
is that SCP-5167's anomalous effects will
become inert by the end of the year.
Whether it'll keep popping up in these video
game matches is another story, though.
It was just as the director had explained.
SCP-5167’s cases were becoming less severe.
They were almost becoming irrelevant, so much
so that the Foundation hypothesized that the
anomaly’s declining potency would lead to
its neutralization before long.
An entity fading into irrelevance and obscurity
once more.
If you haven’t figured it out yet, maybe
SCP-5167’s username will spell it out for
you.
When the entity joined games of Among Us,
it made sure that everyone knew who it was.
Well, everyone would know who it was if the
entity had managed to maintain any form of
popularity over the past dozen centuries or
so.
That’s right.
SCP-5167 would join under the name Phthonus.
The god’s new life had thrust it into the
modern-day, except this time it was inside
the game of Among Us, where it was forced
to cope with the reality that the world seemed
to be more obsessed with a trendy game than
any god or mythological figure.
While inside the game, Phthonus was one bitter
individual.
During emergency meetings, instead of trying
to figure out if red was sus or not, the god
would just yell at the players around him!
One player asked Phthonus what they were doing
while the rest of the crew was performing
their tasks.
To which, Phthonus poetically responded.
“Where was I?
I was there when the mountains were newborn,
and the oceans virginal.
I was there when gods walked among men, and
their wisdom was cast down like sunlight.
I was there when mankind was capable of legends.
And now?
I find myself in a world that has forgotten
even the taste of life, even the very concept
of life beyond existing from one day to the
next.
Mere continuance.
Where all the world is wasted away in idle
play of emotions that once rang true.
I am in a world where even the gods are forgotten,
their bones washed away by time.
A world where man has moved on, where all
the legacy I have left are three sentences
on Wikipedia.
I thought my time had come again.
I thought this could be the new me.
But this is nothing.
Let me stay dead this time.
I'm tired.”
To which, the other players responded, in
typical Among Us fashion, that Phthonus was
“sus”.
He was promptly voted as the impostor, and
ejected from the airlock.
And so, the tragic tale of Phthonus came to
a close.
A tired, obscure God who never had a place
in the world.
His presence in Among Us grew less and less
as the game’s popularity waned, and once
again he would fade into obscurity.
But the nature of Phthonus meant that he would,
in some form, return one day.
Where, or how, no one could say.
But as long as there was a situation to reap
envy from, a trend to be jealous of, Phthonus
would remain, eternally doomed to suffer the
fate of being nobody’s favorite god.
And frankly, we can’t imagine this video
will change that.
Now go check out “SCP Minecraft World Destroyer
SCP-4335 - A Welt In The Crucible” and “SCP-5254
- Gotta Catch 'Em All” for more of the most
absurd anomalies out there!